this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks Dave um Donny
Peter Woodbury and I are just
researchers and I wanna just say um
thanks to Dave wolf and eigen markets
for squirting us so that just the
researchers just the farmers just the
policymakers just the educators can meet
in a room together and come up with a
just plan um and you know climate change
I've been doing it for a while and I I
went through a period of despair and I
no longer have that sense there because
it is one gigantic puzzle and it's
providing us an opportunity to join
forces because soil health water quality
and air quality are all connected to our
great lunches that we on that day like
today
um so theorem okay so just to frame the
talk for how far as landowners and
citizens can remote resilience thank you
the soil I'm going to give you one
example right with climate change we
have a longer growing season so we have
an opportunity for double cropping which
increases the sequestration and slows
the rate of climate change it increases
the resilience resiliency by reducing
erosion it reduces the impact from
extreme weather events by being able to
absorb extreme precipitation and it
increases productivity because we're
working to which results in local and
global sustainability increasing
knowledge and maximizing impacts for
future generations right this is equal
and we can see
so just to give some context Cuomo has
an executive order 166 which has a goal
of 40 by 30 which is a 40 percent
reduction in 1990 levels of greenhouse
gases by 2030 and 80 by 50
that's an 80 percent reduction by 2050
all sectors right this is a huge group
effort and there's tons of program on
that there are out there to support
these agendas and if you haven't seen
some of these names look for them
because there are opportunities on the
list in there now when we talk about
greenhouse gases most people think about
co2 because indeed most of our
greenhouse gases conference po2 that's
the big piece of that pie but two
smaller pieces are methane and nitrous
oxide and the reason I say this is
because in agriculture we need to think
beyond carbon dioxide we must also
consider methane and nitrous oxide today
I will be talking a little bit about
nitrous oxide related to nitrogen
fertilizer in the soil but methane
applies to other act practices so the
reason why it's important to talk about
these other greenhouse gases is that
they have different global warming
potentials and these different gases
have different impacts on the Earth's
warming and in order to compare them or
think about them we have this equation
so if co2 by definition is a global
warming potential of one and you need to
notice is that nitrous oxide is 300
times more potent of a greenhouse gas
and co2 my point being here is managing
nitrogen on your shield is incredibly
important right because it has that
factorial
so how do we avoid emitting greenhouse
gases some examples involving carbon
dioxide and nitrous oxide but we can
avoid producing carbon-based greenhouse
gases we reduce tractor passes we reduce
tillage we reduce synthetic nitrogen
purchase bright synthetic nitrogen is a
really energy intensive process so
you're reducing the fuel used at that
stage or you can avoid the greenhouse
gas impact for nitrogen processes they
reduce your synthetic nitrogen use to
reduce the field nitrous oxide emissions
and you manage your manure to also
reduce nitrous oxide
some ways that we can mitigate or reduce
greenhouse gasses that the soil is
sequestering the carbon dioxide in soils
in food products or other products root
systems wood or wood products we can do
this through promoting vegetative cover
perennials cover crops improve faster
and grazing add biochars or other
amendments to soil increased yield by
dropping like rows of trees buffer
strips and we forest marginal lands and
manager with lakhs to increase the
carbon in both the trees and in this
plan
one of the important things though when
thinking about carbon sequestration
particularly with soils is this concept
of permanence for carbon sequestration
to have a meaningful impact on the
atmosphere it's necessary to ensure that
the carbon and millions equestrians not
released to the atmosphere though years
of carbon buildup thanks was can be
released back to the atmosphere and the
very short period of time so the point
here is some strategies are permanent
and others are not so much but all of
the soil health strategies we've been
talking about today are important for
productivity right so we're just some
things are better and applicable to
mitigating climate change and others in
the right
so just to summarize conserve or improve
vegetative covers so we can protect
agriculture and forest lands from
development defense we move toward slow
sequestration mechanisms including
perennials double crops
cover crops reduced tillage biochar and
improved reasoning why do we do that
these practices sequester kerbin they
improve productivity they reduce erosion
improve water quality and improve swing
improve nutrient management we reduce
the synthetic nitrogen consumption to
reduce the upstream emissions from
producing that and this is both for
agriculture lands but also for
landscapers right yards mmm management
or and synthetic nitrogen on the field
to reduce field nitrous oxide emissions
why do we do this they remove emissions
from fertilizer manufacturing they
improve profitability they improve water
quality improve air quality and improve
improve forest management so more than
60% of our state soil is forested and
30% is on AG land 30% of a ground is
wooded so Farms can manage their wood
Lots on why these practices sequester
carbon in tree trunks soil profitable
long-lived wood products reduce erosion
improve water quality air quality so
improve soil health reduces greenhouse
gases so as farms increased soil carbon
that increase creases the soil health
the crop productivity the water
infiltration and retention and can also
sequester's carbon in the soil and being
the products that we want to feel these
mechanisms include tillage practices
amendments annual vs. perennial crops
cover crops double crepes and this one
marginal ends
now how do we do it I'm just going to
say that there are lots of opportunities
out there and we need to start
leveraging these opportunities for these
multiple benefits so there are climate
smart community grants that are due July
27th for municipalities and the projects
include but are not limited to reduction
of future flood risks so for
implementation of municipal food waste
and composting programs right so there's
some work there there's trees for
tributaries this is a application that's
due in September for planting trees
along waterways as buffer strips - for
nutrient benefit but also it has a time
and change mitigating
in February of 2018 and possibly in have
year of 2019 the climate-resilient
farming allocates two million dollars
available and it covers 75% of the cost
and his money is for agricultural waste
storage cover entire systems riparian
buffer system stream corridor gene
control rotational grazing and soil
conservation systems and on the horizon
the climate action reserve which is a
carbon trading reserve is revising their
nitrogen management credits I and those
should be coming out student has another
way to fund nitrogen management on your
bakery
future needs we need assessments to
better quantify the financial
environmental benefits and costs we need
to promote the best management practices
that we're already doing but also
include greenhouse gas mitigation for
climate change adaptation and long-term
resiliency and we need to create some
policies to provide science-based
information to policymakers as they
negotiate a multitude of societal needs
and I guess what I would like to do is
open it up for questions or comments
particularly on how we can think about
taking climate change into the next
generation of our work
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu